hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast disrupting sexually
transmitted diseases by leveraging
innovative technologies for prevention
an overview of global and local STD
trends and impact presented by dr. Joan
mjau chief surveillance epidemiology
assessment and evaluation section
sexually transmitted disease control
branch California Department of Public
Health I'm Alexis Krause of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by leveraged and
sponsored by Roche molecular diagnostics
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation and the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support tab found at the top-right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus suffers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr. Joan Schell
dr. Jo Ellen specialist
please go ahead sorry it's okay we would
like to now introduce our presenter dr.
John Chow dr. Chow has been a specialist
with the University of California San
Francisco School of Medicine and with
the California Department of Public
Health sexually transmitted disease
control branch since 1997 her areas of
interest have been in evaluation of new
chlamydia diagnostic technologies
surveillance for reproductive health
complications including pelvic
inflammatory disease associated with
chlamydia infections and women chlamydia
and gonorrhea prevalence monitoring and
Family Planning populations development
of chlamydia gonorrhea screening
guidelines and evaluation of quality
improvement interventions aimed at
increasing chlamydia screening and other
STD quality measures dr. Chow you may
now begin your presentation Thank You
Alexis again good morning I am honored
to be invited by Roche Diagnostics to
speak on today's topic this material
reflects my personal opinion and work
and does not reflect that of the sponsor
nor my institution I have no disclosures
to share
the learning objectives for today's talk
are as follows first to describe global
and local trends in bacterial Dutch we
transmitted diseases also known as STDs
and priority populations at risk
secondly to discuss gaps and access to
effective STD prevention strategies and
third describe innovative technologies
and policies that can improve access to
STD screening and diagnosis and
ultimately disrupt xvii here is an
overview for how I would like to achieve
those learning objectives I wanted to
start with an orientation as to why STD
control programs are an important
component of STD prevention on a
population level and describe the
functional framework for how these
programs implement prevention the
majority of the talk will cover both
global and local STD trends through 2017
and how the epidemiology informs our
prevention priorities I'll be focusing
on the bacterial STDs which are syphilis
congenital syphilis gonorrhea and
chlamydia I'll finish with a summary of
STD prevention priorities as well as
innovative solutions and potential
partnerships to address those priorities
so why are STDs a major public health
priority for prevention this map from
the World Health Organization shows the
burden of curable bacterial STDs as of
2016 which include chlamydia gonorrhea
syphilis and trichomoniasis the burden
you can see is huge across continents
from 18 million up to 142 million unique
parts of the world STDs are also a major
prevention priority in the United States
as they are the most commonly reported
communica condition the latest data
released by the US Centers for Disease
Control for 2016 reflects a third
straight year of increases for the three
reportable bacterial conditions Commedia
gonorrhea and syphilis for chlamydia we
have over one-and-a-half million cases
representing a five percent increase
since the prior year 2015
name the gonorrhea nearly half a million
cases and a 20% rate increase in 2015
and for primary secondary syphilis
stages over 27,000 cases also a 20%
increase in 2015 however you should note
that these reported cases are just the
tip of the iceberg Satterwhite and
colleagues from the CDC estimated that
in twenty two thousand eight there were
actually an estimated 20 million new
bacterial and viral STDs with nearly 50%
being acquired by young men and women
aged 15 to 24 most of these infections
were asymptomatic and had the potential
to cause adverse reproductive outcomes
such as infertility neonatal
complications and increased risk for
acquiring or transmitting HIV looking
more locally at California data in
California has a population of 35
million and we see the same pattern
where not only our STDs the most
commonly reported conditions but we also
see that these trends have also been
increasing here are the trends for the
three major reportable bacterial STDs in
California shown here with chlamydia and
green gonorrhea and red and early
syphilis combining primary secondary
syphilis and early latent in blue
starting from 1990 to 2017 based on
reports to date when we see that
chlamydia rates as of 2017 in the green
curve at the top had risen since 1996 to
their highest level at over two hundred
eighteen thousand reported cases our
highest volume since reporting began in
1990 now looking at gonorrhea in the red
we also see that gonorrhea burden in
California has risen to higher than even
1990 with over seventy five thousand
cases and although early syphilis cases
were at a lower volume by orders of
magnitude compared to chlamydia
gonorrhea during this period we have
seen consistent and steady rises from
2000 to now over 13,000 cases by 2017
and so what where and how can public
health and specifically STD control
programs intervene to address this large
and increase
burden this is a really interesting
schematic from the World Health
Organization which developed a global
health sector strategy on sexually
transmitted infections from 2016 to 2021
with an aim towards ending FBI and
starting from the left to illustrate
what is needed for effective control you
can follow the continuum of STD services
that are needed in a population starting
from all people at risk on the left to
those who are reached by primary
prevention activities through to access
to care including being tested and
treated what what I just showed is
really part of a much more coordinated
set of STD prevention activities that
are organized according to these key
areas that are shown here the schematic
that I'm presenting here is for
California but the framework is actually
really pretty common across all STD
prevention programs at both local and
global levels depending on what
resources are available so starting from
the upper left is surveillance and
epidemiology where we collect the data
and assess burden and analyze
characteristics of cases next to that is
health promotion and health care quality
improvement which deals with adherence
to best practices and clinical and
laboratory settings for screening
diagnosis and treatment below that is
local capacity building which actually
enables access to technical assistance
and training for local health
departments to actually implement STD
control moving to the left is disease
intervention which is about addressing
sex partner network to ensure testing
and treatment to interrupt transmission
beyond in the community at the bottom is
medical and scientific fairs that
ensures that Preventionist measures are
evidence-based and can be translated to
practice and lastly policy and
communications are also core to FDA
control for identifying and dressing
structural changes that are necessary
for supporting effective prevention
strategies whether through regulation
change or ensuring access to central
health services for each of the
following bacterial STDs I will discuss
where this framework can be used to
identify effective
and strategy now let's start with
syphilis which is noted here and have
very serious complications which when
left untreated can ultimately lead to
neurosyphilis ocular and otic syphilis
and congenital syphilis and stillbirth
confer babies exposed in utero globally
after many years of low STD and low
syphilis rates almost to the point of
elimination there has been a striking
resurgence that is disproportionately
impacted men who have sex with men noted
here is MSM this review by ybarra and
colleague summarized the increases in
syphilis infections among MSM
in the US and also multiple countries in
Western Europe from 1998 the period with
the fewest syphilis infections onwards
toward through 2013 similarly in the
United States there was a increase in
primary and secondary syphilis the
symptomatic stages of syphilis which
started at the same time globally in the
early 2000 and here the increases were
seen across all region of the regions of
the United States and have accelerate
accelerated with about a 20% increase as
noted earlier as of 2016 in California
the same increases have been seen here
since 2000 to 2017 early syphilis cases
in California were also predominantly
male with near doubling of cases and
rate of nearly 60 400,000 since 2013 as
seen here in blue however you'll note
the bottom in red
female case rates have also increased
but they've increased Eightfold since
2013 to a rate of 8.5 400,000 reflecting
a much more recent increase in
heterosexual syphilis transmission and
I'll come back to this recent trend in a
few slides here we see a further
breakdown of twice 17 early syphilis
cases in California by sex and gender or
sex partners so starting on the left
side of the chart we see that 28% of
early syphilis cases are among HIV
positive
MSM 32% of early syphilis cases are HIV
negative MSM 27% of early syphilis cases
are men having sex with women or men
with an unknown gender or sex partner
and 13% are females but given this
profile of early syphilis cases there
are clear prevention opportunities for
ensuring linkage to care for HIV
positive MSM syphilis cases as well as
navigation to prep pre-exposure
prophylaxis for HIV negative MSM early
syphilis cases on what might be factors
that have contributed to syphilis
increases among men having sex with men
when you receive trans and specific
venues for meeting sex partners as
reported in California syphilis case
interviews among MSM early syphilis
cases we see here internet or mobile
apps in blue bars and clubs and orange
and vas houses and sex clubs in grey
trends since 2007 uses the Internet
including mobile apps using fish facial
analysis or geo-locating functionality
has been the most commonly reported
venue among men having sexist men early
syphilis cases much more so than bars
and clubs bath houses and sex club
we're going to look a little bit more
closely at the internet venues for
meeting partners and you see that in
this slide showing the frequency of
these different types of internet pen
use that Grindr has been the most common
mobile app for finding partners and has
been frequently cited as a reason for
syphilis increases at least in
California
among all interviewed early syphilis
cases the percent recording meeting
partners online was thirty two percent
among MSM and then having pectus men and
women as compared to six percent among
men having sex with women and less than
four percent among female in California
syphilis and HIV co-infection rates are
high therefore ensuring HIV testing of
individuals with an STD is a standard of
care in STD prevention and control this
particular national program outcome
measure in the United States is used to
analyze the percent new HIV testing
amongst syphilis cases that were
initiated for follow-up by the local
health jurisdiction and the associated
new HIV positivity amongst those who are
tested they want to mention a few data
are really critical for improving
linkage to HIV care for newly HIV
infected individuals and to prep for
those who are HIV negative as I noted on
the previous slide you can see here on
the right that in the california project
area and San Francisco's little over
half just over half of early syphilis
cases who are eligible actually received
HIV testing and pretty consistently
though where HIV testing does occur the
yields are high about six to seven
percent HIV positivity in California and
San Francisco thus making a case for why
HIV testing among syphilis cases is
cost-effective conversely what about
stuff with screening among HIV clients
we also know that HIV care clients are
at risk for syphilis and therefore
there's our national recommendations for
syphilis screening among MSM clients in
a chai
karriker the Centers for Disease Control
so this truck shows variation by city
and state in the proportion of H of MSM
clients and HIV care settings that were
screened for syphilis and the California
project area is shown here at the lower
end at 42% so there's definitely work to
be done so how can STD programs use this
type of information can we leverage the
internet and mobile apps to increase STD
HIV testing and I think the answer is
yes Grindr actually has launched new
opt-in HIV testing reminders to help to
users to get testing to occur more
regularly per these national guidelines
and they actually have a huge market
they're promoting this to their over 3.6
million users to find HIV testing sites
in the US by networking with over 200
LGBT community based organizations and
this is their website here that is also
being promoted through a partnership
with the National Coalition of STD
directors called building healthy online
communities however I wanted to go back
to the other concerning increase in
syphilis that we saw for women in
California where the early syphilis rate
increased seven times during the past
five years also wanted to note that
we've been seeing recent increases in
heterosexual syphilis globally as well
and here is a recent reports in Japan
where similar similar increases have
been seen among women in a population
Reese if I spend
relatively uncommon
looking at the US data trends the
highest increases are also particularly
screening for women of reproductive age
that is ages 15 to 44 this infographic
shows the connection between syphilis
increases among women and increases in
congenital syphilis which rose by 28% in
2015 to 2016 in the United States in
2007 the World Health Organization
launched the global elimination of
congenital syphilis initiative with a
goal of reducing mother-to-child
transmission is syphilis to a
sufficiently low level that congenital
syphilis was no longer a public health
problem and the goal was for countries
to achieve a congenital syphilis rate of
50 or fewer cases per hundred thousand
live births through achieving
programmatic targets of more than 95%
syphilis screening coverage in pregnancy
and more than 95% treatment of ceará
positive women and in this graphic each
pair of bars shows the contribution of
different regions in the world to the
decreases since 2007 when this
initiative was was introduced decreases
in stillbirth preterm and low birth
weight babies meaning death and syphilis
infected infants
and so the five year update essentially
found that there was a 38 percent
reduction in the number of pregnant
women with syphilis and in the number of
congenital syphilis cases across the
board but internationally Angelica was
still accounts for almost two hundred
thousand perinatal deaths each year
looking locally at at California data we
see that the same concerning increases
for early syphilis rates are have been
occurring among women which have
increased four times since 2013 this
chart shows the consequences for
increases in California female early
syphilis rates on congenital syphilis
trends and this chart trends in early
syphilis rates amongst females of
childbearing age are shown by the black
line curve and congenital syphilis cases
are shown in yellow bars this increasing
trend in both female and Kajal syphilis
rates is apparent since 2012 when both
conditions were at their lowest point
Kajal syphilis cases rose from a low of
33 cases in 2012 for a fifth straight
year to a level of 278 cases and twice
seventeen and eight fold increase
Dilbert trends amongst the congenital
support cases have also increased and
the numbers have tripled from 12 in 2016
to 36 and 2017 and hence this increase
in Kajal so forth in female syphilis
happens to be a major local prevention
priority CDC recognized that recent
persistent trends affecting both males
females now babies required a much more
coordinated and robust response and you
should be aware that in 2017 the Centers
for Disease Control released a
call-to-action document outlining
recommended strategies reinforcing
screening treatment and partner services
for priority populations including women
of childbearing age and I focused here
on a specific call in the box for
University in industry collaborations to
develop and bring to market novel
syphilis tests and to conduct clinical
research to assess the performance for
effective prevention this slide takes
the gaps in STD prevention program
prevention for syphilis and offers some
innovative solutions for syphilis
control
forces first and foremost improving that
syphilis screening is a priority for
prenatal patients and hiv-positive men
having sex with men and so in the aro
what we've proposed are how that might
happen and one approach and solution
would include creating multiplex testing
platforms that address multiple
conditions including syphilis HIV and
also hepatitis C virus specifically we
would be able to improve the specificity
of diagnosis of primary lesions for
instance and also add Treponema primers
to two other assays such as herpes
simplex virus point of care testing is
absolutely a priority for increasing
access to screening particularly for
hard-to-reach populations and one way
that might occur would be to actually
develop point of care testing that
combines non trepan email and trêpa
Nimal confirmatory testing
clearly there are some issues in terms
of how best to create such such tests
and and design issues are paramount you
know related to being able to address
fuel conditions temperature requirements
reagent stability and in order to really
make point of care testing happen
particularly in the field we have to
address some policy issues regarding
certification certification and training
of local disease intervention staff and
non-medical staff so they're actually
able to conduct these chronic care tests
in the field
so let's now turn to gonorrhea trans
gonorrhea prevention is also a national
priority because basically gonorrhea has
grown resistant to nearly every drug
ever used to treat it we are now down to
one recommended treatment for gonorrhea
stuff with forums and we know that
increasing multi drug-resistant
Neisseria gonorrhea reports are a major
concern for ongoing control of these
infections the World Health Organization
Global gonococcal antimicrobial
surveillance program or gap is key to
monitoring and microwaveable resistance
trends for gonorrhea internationally and
they identify emerging antibiotic
resistance and therefore use these data
to inform regular changes to the
treatment guidelines and public health
policy on a global basis in vitro and
clinical resistance to Neisseria
gonorrhea to the extended spectrum
separate forums the last line treatment
for gonorrhea have been reported from
many particularly well resourced
settings on a global basis you can see
here in the map sometimes as high as 30%
as shown in gold and up to 5% as shown
in yellow
the emergence of antibiotic resistant
gonorrhea is especially concerning given
recent trends in gonorrhea incidents
after decades of major declines in
gonorrhea since the 1970s and low rates
in the last ten years we have started to
see increases in the United States in
2016 a total of almost 500,000 cases of
gonorrhea were reported in the United
States and represented a nearly 20
percent increase since 2015 and a 50
percent increase since the historic low
in 2009 in this graph showing the annual
trend locally in California since 1990
you can see the dramatic increase as
well after the mid-1990s especially for
male gonorrhea cases and rates increased
by 17% over 2016 gonorrhea cases and
nearly doubled since 2013 about
two-thirds of our gonorrhea cases in
California now are among men men who
have sex with men make up about 43% of
our total cases but out of just men they
make up nearly two-thirds of all male
cases where gonorrhea case is likely to
be diagnosed in California so we use our
case data to look at providers that are
diagnosing MSM men having sex with women
and female cases and noted that there
were key differences in in provider type
STD clinics and private providers were
the most frequently reported provider
type for MSM gonorrhea cases while
private providers and emergency
departments we're the most common for
men having sex with women and family
planning was by far the most common for
females here we see the distribution of
site of infection by sexual orientation
for California gonorrhea cases how does
this inform our intervention prevention
strategies it shows that some half of
all reported infections are at extra
general sites amongst MSM screening MSM
at these sites it's necessary to not
miss half or more of gonorrhea
as shown in the lot as shown on the last
slide many MSM gonorrhea cases were
diagnosed at STD clinics so conducting
reciting more frequently at these
clinics is evident in that provider
setting but perhaps not so much so in
other provider settings how do the
recommendations to conduct free site
testing affect our development of
diagnostic tools for our program
conducts a California Clinical
Laboratory survey every few years new
data is in use useful for understanding
laboratory testing for each of the STDs
so here we see the transferred gonorrhea
test types where the Green Line shows
the increase in the use of nucleic acid
amplification test for gonorrhea during
the 2000s where it has been the most
common test type the higher sensitivity
of nucleic acid amplification test for
GC extra general testing compared to
culture has definitely improved our
ability to diagnose and treat these
otherwise undetected infections
adherence to three site testing may well
have been a factor an increased
gonorrhea case reporting particularly in
San Francisco in LA in California in
contrast to the increase in the nucleic
acid amplification tip gonorrhea culture
shown here in blue has declined from
about 40 percent of gonorrhea test to
less than 5% of all gonorrhea test
conductor in California so what are the
implications for understanding trends in
gonorrhea and a microtubule
susceptibility trend a concerning issue
that we started this section with the
Centers for Disease Control has been
monitoring gonorrhea and microbial
resistance patterns via a multi-site
network of STD clinics which submitted
25 isolates per month for Ana microbial
susceptibility testing as local public
health laboratories and CDC's exclusive
surveillance effort that is similar to
what I mentioned earlier that is being
conducted by the World Health
Organization
as noted earlier we are down to the last
antibiotic class of cephalus florins for
gonorrhea treatment which now consists
of dual therapy with trioxin injection
as well as as if from Ison and here we
see the annual trends and the percent of
gonorrhea eye slits with m.i.c alert
values associated with a decreased
susceptibility from 1992 to 2017 just in
California the orange portion of the
bars indicates the 16 and the red bar
indicates ceftriaxone increases in m.i.c
alert values for 16 resulted in changes
in treatment recommended recommendations
such that is no longer a recommended
first-line treatment so the take-home
points here from this slide are that the
percent of isolates with alert values is
declining and that there have been no
treatment failures in the United States
however have there have been reports of
gonorrhea cases in Japan and most
recently in the UK that required much
higher doses of ceftriaxone clearly
enhanced international collaborative
actions are crucial for the depart of
the control of gonorrhea
so in this slide based on the
information that I've just presented on
what is happening in terms of gonorrhea
trends and particularly with regard to
animai resistant patterns here are some
of the STD program gaps and possible
innovative solutions for gonorrhea
control going forward so clearly FDA
clearance for extra general assessments
and increased three site testing is is
paramount and needs to occur so that we
can expand access to identification of
these infections and that could also be
implemented more effectively through
home collected your general and extra
general assessments being able to expand
those FDA claims beyond self collected
vaginal specimens in u.s. clinical sense
would actually be a major major
advancement secondly being able to
develop rapid molecular point-of-care
tests to detect antibiotic resistance
for symptomatic versus asymptomatic
patients would be another major priority
there are some issues with respect to
determining what is the right target for
molecular assay work whether it's
targeting 10a or jar a and what other
assay could be this type of detection
deep combined with it's possible to to
go forward I think with the work that's
been done by Roche for instance in
developing a separate test within the
lab and a tube platform as a
confirmatory to complement our my
screening for for syphilis
here's an example of how our academic
partners are developing diagnostic
solutions along these lines that can
help us treat gonorrhea infections with
appropriate antibiotics UCLA researchers
developed a real-time reverse
transcription polymerase chain reaction
for tests for a mutation of codon 91 in
the jar der a gene and Neisseria
gonorrhea that reliably predicts
resistances ciprofloxacin dipper was a
drug that was associated with a high
proportion of isolates with decreased
susceptibility in the early 2000s with
this particular test that takes 24 to 48
hours it's possible perhaps to actually
revert back to a treatment that was
taken off the the recommended treatment
guidelines in order to expand our
ability to to treat gonorrhea
now let's take a look at chlamydia
trends
in 2016 a total of over one and a half
million chlamydia infections were
reported to the US Centers for Disease
Control and has been the most commonly
reported communica conditions since
reporting was initiated during 2015 to
2016 the overall rate increased almost
5% in 2016 the rate of reported cases of
chlamydia among women with two times the
rate among men and that probably likely
due to the patterns of care for women
compared to men however during 2012 to
2016 the rate and men increased over 25
percent and that may reflect increasing
access for men to chlamydia immediate
testing particularly through urine
testing
chlamydia remains the most commonly
reported in California as well there
were over two hundred and eighteen
thousand chlamydia cases in 2017 the
highest volume since reporting began in
1990
excuse me
I'm just gonna take that thank you this
is the highest volume since reporting
began in 1990 likely as a result of
increased screening of young women perd
national recommendations for media cases
increased by 10% over 2016 cases and
increased by 30% since 2013
and here again we see a sari
great thank you and here again we see
the trend in the types of chlamydia test
by test type of based on our chlamydia
annual lab survey from 1996 to 2012 and
as we saw with with gonorrhea the
proportion of tests for chlamydia that
has been based on nucleic acid
amplification has increased dramatically
since 1996 to the point where it you
know as of 2012 they are the most common
test type as they are for chlamydia for
gonorrhea for chlamydia and that's
largely because of the combination
assays that detect both these infections
in the same specimen at the same time
that the proportion for nucleic acid
amplification tests has increased
there's an a major major decline in the
proportion of tests that are conducted
via culture and also by DNA probe here
we see some of the underlying trends for
why chlamydia infections have been
increasing over the last two decades we
see consistently increasing trends in
both national and local program rates of
chlamydia screening for young women
however you'll see that they're also
gaps in screening that remain
these national numbers come from both
managed care as well as from local
health program set that served women and
family planning setting rescreening to
prevent repeat chlamydia and gonorrhea
infection is also critical to prevention
of pelvic inflammatory disease and
infertility and here we see that the
repeat positivity is revised 15% for
chlamydia and 10% for gonorrhea for
women who were rescreened within six
months after initial infection however
we see that there are also gaps in
rescreening
as well and based on family planning
clinic data we see that only a third of
women treated for chlamydia are actually
retested within six months of treatment
per CDC recommendations but amongst
those who actually did return to the
clinic
um these are also another quarter were
not retested as well so these reflect
output missed opportunities for
identifying repeat infection for these
women so here is a summary of prevention
priorities innovative solutions and
potential partnerships to address the
challenge of the gaps that we've
identified one is definitely there is a
need to improve access to STD HIV
testing and here are some of the
solutions certainly we need to work on
FDA clearance for home collected vaginal
and extra general assessments for both
chlamydia and gonorrhea
we need rapid CLIA waived test for non
clinical settings which include
Corrections homeless setting
reservations for where Native Americans
reside or any other areas with poor
access to health where mobile clinics
might be an important setting for for
testing we certainly need prevalence
studies in order to provide the evidence
for cost effective identification for
infections in those settings so it's
unclear whether or not we need to have a
randomized control trial to just to
develop that that evidence base for
identifying these infections more
effectively and certainly this type of
new type of data would be helpful to
inform the US Preventive task force
recommendations as well as climate CDC
STD treatment guidelines for supporting
screening in these particular specimen
sites and then from a policy perspective
and advocacy there needs to be evidence
for cost-effectiveness and return on
investment with regard to a screening in
in these settings we need information
data on cost and yield and the adverse
outcomes that are averted as a result of
screening for these infections in these
populations and these specimen types
another major policy issue have to do
with reimbursement for tests who is
actually paying
four increases in STD and HIV testing
which test should be covered in benefits
is a policy issue and who should pay
should it be the Centers for the CMS in
the United States should be managed care
plans who decides whether these tests
are included under capitation fees
versus fee-for-service
so I just wanted to make sure that
everyone had access to resources that
that might help further local
decision-making and policymaking with
regard to expanding STD screening
recently April was declared f.2d
Awareness Month in the in California and
so we disseminated resources in
collaboration with the CDC through their
websites and kdq and also to our website
and I've put down here where you could
access some of the other documents that
are referenced such as the CDC call to
action with regard to syphilis
reduction in syphilis gonorrhoea and
possibly chlamydia going forth is
possible as indicated by these
projections by the World Health
Organization if there is a coordinated
effort along the lines of the STD
control program framework I started with
the WH o is using this framework to
project what seems like an ambitious
goal a reduction of 90% in the burden at
least for syphilis and gonorrhea
worldwide and I believe that with public
and private partnerships globally and
locally I think that probably is
possible to disrupt STDs both globally
and locally thank you and I'm now ready
for questions thank you dr. Chow for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is
you have made a strong case for the
continued development and utilization of
point-of-care tests for syphilis to
increase access to screening
particularly for hard to reach at-risk
groups what are some of the research and
policy barriers that need to be overcome
to facilitate the use of these
point-of-care tests that's a really
important aspect I think of local of STD
control particularly for these
hard-to-reach populations that don't
access clinical settings so we've kind
of data that we have really is from
small outbreak response type efforts by
county and state STD programs so I think
being able to do a much more systematic
assessment of these efforts of using
poincare tests such as syphilis
point-of-care trip animal point-of-care
test is really important we don't see
much of those data being reported in the
literature and so I think the the type
of data that are available when the
point-of-care tests are being used in
the field tends to be based on small
sample sizes and lacks actually cost
data and so if we had a lot of that cost
data to demonstrate that the yield the
return on investment in these settings
is high I think we can absolutely make a
better case for implementing
point-of-care tests in these types of
settings the other issue with regard to
policy I think I alluded to earlier had
to do with reimbursement and funding for
these point-of-care tests often local
health departments are really really
pretty limited in their ability to pay
for these tests other issues have to do
with restrictions on who actually can
conduct these tests we've been very
fortunate to work with with companies
that provide
on the training for these point-of-care
tests and are actually very very helpful
in implementing these these screenings
in these settings so those are two
particular areas I think where we could
absolutely work to improve the
acceptability and the feasibility for
implementing point-of-care tests and I
think I also alluded to some technical
issues regarding the performance of
these poincare tests and how they might
be designed we certainly need the
smallest least resource intensive type
point-of-care tests to be developed for
use in these these settings so they can
be an accurate reflection of of disease
burden in the field
okay to dr. Chow our next question since
gonorrhea has become resistant to
practically all except cephalosporin are
there cases where patients are resistant
to cephalosporin
right now there are no treatment
failures that that I am aware of in the
United States and based on the reports
from Japan and the UK basically the
patients who have not responded to stop
less Borden's at least using the 250 and
the 500 milligram and up to 1 milligram
doses of Steph trioxin have responded to
even two other types of of antibiotics
that are not widely available such as
gentamicin and a couple of other
experimental drugs but these are not
fully vetted I think in clinical trial
settings to enable them to be
recommended as true alternative
treatments by the CDC
do you think that the use of prep is
contributing to the increase in esti is
well it's an interesting question
certainly up for debate based on some of
the off-label
data coming from from France from the
Ypres gay and from other countries where
prep has prep uptake has been increasing
over the last couple of years since prep
was was made available the
recommendations for Inc for anywhere
from three to six months screening for
STDs has also been potentially a factor
for why those rates for STDs bacterial
STDs have been increasing it's really
hard to tell whether people who are on
prep are also practicing precautions
with regard to condom use at the same
time that they're using prep and so I
think we definitely need to see more
data on a follow-up of prep patients who
are with regard to the use of condoms
and within their sexual partner networks
but it certainly has been interesting to
see the chorus be concurrent increases
in prep as well as STDs among MSM in the
last two years so it's a possible factor
but you also have to deal with the fact
that we're screening to identify
infections that may not have been
identified before because of the
recommendations to to screen more
frequently
so dr. Chow considering the trends in
Europe towards home testing what in your
opinion is the biggest hurdle for
widespread implementation in the u.s. I
think and I think you're referring you
said home testing right yes ma'am okay
right now none of the the FDA approved
tests for chlamydia and gonorrhea have
been cleared for home testing right now
the the FDA has approved these for for
clinic settings only and if laboratories
would like to make available access to
testing for specimens that are collected
at home and then sent into the
laboratory that is possible if the
laboratory does a validation to collect
these specimens and demonstrate that
they have the same performance as
specimens that would have been collected
in the clinical setting and one of the
exciting innovations I think in the last
five to ten years has been the
availability of online access to two
chlamydia and gonorrhea testing
Charlotte Gaydos work with developing a
website call I want the kit has been
really really instrumental in enabling
people who do not feel that they can go
to a clinic to to get to submit
assessments and prefer the
confidentiality of mitting assessment by
collecting one at home and sending it in
has been a real real exciting
development I think in expanding access
to confidential services testing
services to to people who need to be
tested and so that expansion of online
testing has been really pretty
remarkable if you go on the website on
the internet you actually see a fair
number of laboratories that will provide
these services and the assumption is
that the
laboratories have satisfied CLIA
validation requirements in order to
receive those specimens that are
collected not in the clinical setting
now STD screening rates do not seem to
be at the optimal levels to effectively
identify and treat asymptomatic STD what
are some barriers that providers face
when adhering to recommend STD screening
guidelines
well providers as you saw in the that
continuum of fue service are a key part
of assuring that when people do access
care that they actually are going to be
assessed for risk and and screened
appropriately and one of the biggest
barriers for providers in this setting
is the tremendous amount of work that
needs to be done within the clinical
setting during the short period of time
that they actually have to see a patient
and so with the emergence of electronic
health records that they are entering
data into I think it's absolutely
possible to facilitate that type of risk
assessment among providers one of the
biggest barriers that that we've
identified for providers is first of all
being aware of risk assessment questions
that they need to ask every sexually
active person or even to determine
whether someone is sexually active and
then to be able to ask the appropriate
questions so that they can understand
what types of of tests need to be done
with the availability of electronic
health records there are some
opportunities actually to build in
alerts within the electronic health
record so is to facilitate not just risk
assessment but also the ability to take
the information from the risk assessment
and determine whether or not a
particular type of STD or HIV test is
recommended for that person I think that
providers also may not be aware because
they haven't been trained to do these
types of assessments and be aware of
these types of of screening and
treatment recommendations and so I think
awareness is another major gap for
providers and the kind of websites that
have been developed I think by the CDC
and local at-te control programs I think
have a lot of them information making
them aware that sharing that with local
providers I think would be a major step
in terms of increasing their ability to
identify opportunities that would
otherwise be missed or patients that
they are seeing so those are I think the
two big issues in terms of awareness and
then also technical assistance for
providers and doctors how it looks like
we're going to have time for one more
question a clear medical need to address
STI s exists in high prevalence
populations which are also often
resource limited can you outline the key
hurdles to implementing screening and
diagnostic tests in these populations
well I think first of all having having
data that shows that there are there is
a high burden in in these settings is
really really critical and I think as I
mentioned before there are small smaller
studies I think that attempt to
demonstrate this having the data to
demonstrate that you know without those
high yields you actually can have a cost
effective yield for implementing these
types of screen programs in high
prevalence populations by corrections
the homeless and so forth is really
really critical I think for convincing
our local partners as well as as
national partners that this is going to
make a wise investment essentially for
reducing STDs it makes the most sense I
think to use the limited resources that
we have on a local level as well as a
national and global level to to really
make decisions where the highest return
on investment is is actually realized by
screening in these populations and you
certainly know from the smaller studies
where they are over the last couple of
years we've seen a real real decrease I
think in the amount of funding that has
been going to local and state STD
programs with regard to testing and
support for partner services for
follow-up and so I think again those are
the areas where you know we need to
invest significant funding we've been
level funded I think on a local and
national level for many years now and in
the context of the increases that that I
just shared I think that's going to be
really really problematic we're at being
asked I think from a public health
perspective to do more with with less
resources and that extends from
everything stemming from access to
condoms and and doing risk reduction
linked through ensuring access to care
preventive services as well as treatment
services to for following up those who
are positive to partner services to
really really expand prevention
throughout the committee of throughout
the community
thank you again dr. Chow do you have any
final comments for our audience
no I hope that this has been an
enlightening presentation for the
audience and happy to receive any any
questions following this presentation
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
the registration we would like to thank
levers and our sponsor Roche molecular
diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through January of 2019
laboratory alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
you